well everyone wants to be a public
figure obviously everyone wants to be
famous but
if you are famous there's a special
burden that you bear right now
if you're a person in the public eye who
dares
even briefly to think for yourself there
is roughly a hundred percent chance that
an organized group of fascists on the
internet is going to try to destroy your
life
they'll get you fired they'll pick at
your house they'll make certain your
kids are miserable
they're not doing it because they like
you or dislike you personally you're
irrelevant they don't care about you
they're doing it because they understand
that truth tends to metastasize
once someone prominent with a megaphone
starts saying true things people hear it
and pretty soon the whole edifice of
lies comes crashing down and the
fascists on the internet have less power
they're revealed as the dishonest thugs
that they are and they don't want that
so they try and crush you before it
happens this is inevitable the question
is how do you respond when they try to
crush you
and they're only two possible options
and both of them it turns out were on
display today
both come from great britain because the
assault on speech and thought is a
global phenomenon
here's the first winston marshall plays
banjo for a terrific folk band called
mumford in sons
marshall has been on the fascist radar
for quite some time now
a few years ago he said something nice
about jordan peterson
now that doesn't mean that winston
marshall is a right winger he probably
isn't
but it does suggest he might be a free
thinker which as we noted is a massive
threat to the fraud industrial complex
finally the other day winston marshall
went too far
he praised andy noe's new book about
antifa
no describes antifa as what it is a
criminal mob but you can't do that right
now because it suggests that there might
be something wrong with hurting people
in order to get what you want
so they decided to destroy winston
marshall and today they succeeded
marshall issued this statement over
twitter quote over the past few days i
have come to better understand the pain
i caused by the book i endorsed
obviously he wrote this at gunpoint but
he still wrote it quote i have offended
not only a lot of people i don't know
but also those closest to me including
my bandmates
and for that i am truly sorry as a
result of my actions
liking a book i am taking time away from
the band to examine my blind spots end
quote
so winston marshall is leaving his job
another victory for the fascists on the
internet
that's one way to handle attacks on
speech just surrender
that's what most famous people do you
see it every day the guy who used to
host the bachelor may never work again
his crime no one even knows what he did
wrong
but he apologized for it anyway but
there's another way to handle those
attacks and it comes from our friend
piers morgan
whom we told you last night just left
his job on a british morning show
after failing to be sufficiently
impressed by that whiny duchess from la
complaining about how hard her life is
now piers morgan knew what the script
was supposed to be
oh you poor oppressed duchess but he
refused to read it
so now he's unemployed today piers
morgan issued this statement quote
on monday i said i didn't believe meghan
markle in her oprah interview
i've had time to reflect on this opinion
and i still don't
if you did okay freedom of speech is a
hill i'm happy to die on
thanks for all the love and hate i'm off
to spend more time with my opinions
so like winston marshall piers morgan is
out of a job tonight
but unlike winston martial morgan told
the truth
he refused to let the mob make him lie
and that is an inspiration to all of us
piers morgan just reminded the world
that some things are more important
than having a job like your dignity and
your self-respect
history will treat him well good for you
pierce morgan